[Musique]
s'il vous plaît, pourriez-vous akan vous taquiner
un tueur Phillipe avant l'aube une fuite après que
nous soyons descendus oui
[Musique]
voir il y a deux ans Tony Lama dan de
quiche dirigeable ne lui a pas donné un centime
Lucien
[Musique]
un  donateur que la force ricean illégalement
Bahama a vu la coupe a vu Estella choisir
de chercher à Dallas un BAM effilé em
seulement venir vivre tu es sûr que
Sheila Dieu tu vois tous les jours maman il saura
t'aimer champagne
qui te connaît enfin
savoir faire du shopping heureux persuader que vous
connaissez notre spectacle pashya défini si devoir ha
fernette ou pologne regardez que dieu
vous bénisse parce que vous il est doux sur le
soleil Potiphar de cheveux jaunes est mort
si cela était plus courageux vous venez de visiter sur
elle devrait chaque faveur
première visite bouton d'accueil  ne sont pas si
durs qu'un échantillon alors que vous pourriez pendant votre
marin mais venez voir est un père de barre
Delgado [ __ ] vous avez dit de deja Donnelly
coupé exemple une question maintenant était mon poisson nous
savons mieux était mon
être pour habiliter Guardian un vieil amant
fatigué déposé chercher  le comité
feta 20 tue émerge allez un
quel
chef afin de rester là samedi
tu sais directeur allez oui
mec nous ne l'avons pas fait il fait un Swami pour
blesser ou pas - quoi se lever après le -
pointu d'une course tant pis  Comté
mon profond
bientôt tout le monde une
célébrité de cinéma en tête-à-tête une graphie au clair de lune
qu'elle avait raillée pour dessiner un sceptre à faire
revoir changer le temps
ne peut pas vomir allez oh oh elle
Chevy est toi pour voir nos vaches
[Musique]
toi  pourrait faire évoluer la
charité Sukie que
nous faisons pour démo clé circulaire
[Musique]
bien que pour chaque homme devrait cette
camaraderie de jeune amour un chaos très pauvre
pour vous, il gardera la grotte un
Fraggle
- le deuxième chef sera dans chaque
étang de decola de DVD manataj familial  derrière la
trivialité
pila masala coupé le service ils ont duré
jusqu'à te voir Dallas c'est une grosse bombe d'oiseau em
vu il est venu te voir sûr qu'elle aime
bébé chaud il saurait comment faire du shopping
tu sais qu'il sait comment Buscemi
je suis sûr que c'est des conneries définitives Iguodala Shiva
ou la maison nette sur le pourrait être cette couleur
douce  Dieu qu'il est doux avec ce docteur
bien ouais sur les 20 devrait avoir une
dérogation que vous recevez à la maison, elle devrait avoir
une priorité ma chérie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]